في يوم مشمس نظر سكان ولايه مونتانا
الامريكيه الى السماء ليخطف نظرهم هذا
المنطاد
لم يعلموا حينها ان ذاك الهيكل هو بالون
تجسس
سريعا كشفت السلطات الامريكيه سر المنطاد
لتعلن انه تابع للصين
بالونات التجسس ما هي لمعدات قديمه اعيد
استخدامها في عالم التجسس الحديث مفهوم
بالونات التجسس ظهرت لاول مره عام 1860
اثناء الحرب الاهليه الامريكيه تقول صحيفه
البريطانيه
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه تم تحديث
مفهوم بالونات التجسس لتحل الكاميرات
المخفيه المعلقه بدلا من الرجال الذين
يحملون المناظر لمراقبه العدو
لم تكت تنتهي الحرب العالميه الثانيه حتى
اطلقت اليابان اول قصف جوي عابر للقارات
مستهدفه الاراضي الامريكيه من خلال مناطيض
مسلحه اطلق عليها فوجو مصنوعه من الورق
والحرير الصناعي وخلال خمسه اشهر فقط
اطلقت اليابان نحو 9000 بالون صوب
الولايات المتحده وفقا للمتحف الوطني
للقوات الجويه الامريكيه استفادت امريكا
من التجربه اليابانيه لتدشن بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه مهمه واسعه النطاق تسمى
مشروع جينيتريكس للتجسس فوق اراضي الاتحاد
السوفيتي خلال فتره الخمسينات عبر مناطيد
التصوير
اذا ما قررنا المنطاد بالقمر الصناعي فانه
يتميز بتغطيه مساحات اوسعه ويتميز بقضاء
وقت اطول فوق المنطقه المستهدفه المنطاد
ايضا يتميز بانه اسهل في الاسترداد وارخص
من حيث تكلفه الانتاج والتشغيل لكن لا
يقدم المنطاد نفس المستوى من الدقه
والكفاءه في المراقبه المستمره كالاقمار
الصناعيه واليوم تعمل مثل هذه المناطير
على ارتفاع يتراوح بين 80,000 الى 120 الف
قدم وهو اعلى بكثير من مدى الطائرات
المدنيه